Hello and welcome to today's Unreal Engine training, which is a quick start to blueprints
for virtual production.
So to give you a bit of an overview of the blueprints that we're going to be covering
today, we'll be talking about blueprint usage and what blueprints are.
We'll dive into the editor and talk about the different interfaces you'll expect to
see within blueprints.
We'll talk about the types of blueprints.
We also have a concept called level blueprints, which we'll give more context to.
And then we'll talk about blueprint classes along with other classes.
We'll talk about some basic scripting terms.
We'll talk about interfaces and how you communicate between different blueprints.
And then we'll also finish up with some inheritance.